ja showdown beim größten hollywood
prozess des jahres vor gericht johnny
depp und amber heard und heute könnte
das urteil fallen ja kurz davor ist
johnny depp ganz im stil eines
hollywoodstars nach den schlussplädoyers
aus amerika für ein paar tage nach
england geflüchtet und hat dort erstmal
auf rockstar gemacht hier sehen wir ihn
auf der bühne das ist das konzert von
gitarren guru jeff beck seinem kumpel
[Musik]
da ist ein bisschen musik am morgen tut
er auch mal ganz gut geld die flickr ist
für uns leid vor dem gerichtsgebäude in
fairfax im us bundesstaat virginia guten
morgen liebe katie ja heute tag der tage
das urteil soll fallen du begleitet für
uns diesen prozess von tag eins an was
denkst du wie wird das heute ausgehen ja
also es ist da habe ich bin auch hin-
und hergerissen man kann es nicht sagen
weil es geht natürlich sind sehr viele
beweise haben über 40 zeugen gehört denn
sieben wochen es kam audioaufnahmen
videoaufnahmen aber schlussendlich geht
es nur darum wem die jury glaubt er es
hat viel mit emotionen zu tun wer kommt
kann glaubt glaubwürdige rüber für die
jury es geht kann auch teilweise gar
nicht um die beweise so sehr gehen
sondern ist es ja ganz anders als in
deutschland wo dann ein richter
entscheiden ist es hier das sind sieben
geschworenen das ganz normale menschen
sind das sind keine rechtsexperten sind
kein entertainment experten da sind
einfach
stichprobenartig wurden die hieraus der
ist im umkreis gewählt und da bekommt
man natürlich dann ein urteil das
bereich teilweise sehr nachvollziehbar
ist aber das kann natürlich auch ganz
anders ausgehen als jeder experte dass
er vor aussieht
könnte die folge denn tatsächlich eine
haftstrafe sein nein also das ist ja
jetzt hier ein zivilprozess das heißt es
verklagt johnny depp klagt emma herzig
gegenklage eingereicht aber es ist kein
kriminalfall das heißt es gibt keine
absprache ist es nur ein reiner
zivilprozess wo es ums geld geht und
umarmen auch uns recht zu haben aber es
geht um sehr viel geld hat muss man an
dieser stelle auch noch mal betonen
katie bleib ruhig bei uns wir wollen
nämlich noch mal auf ein paar von
johnnys schrägsten moment schauen
es ist einer der schmutzigsten prozesse
vor gericht johnny depp versus amber
heard trotz der gegenseitigen
gewaltvorwürfe gibt es aber auch einiges
zum schmunzeln
nicht zuletzt dank der der sich gefühlt
durch nichts und niemanden aus der ruhe
bringen ist die skurrilsten momente
platz fünf
[Musik]
war
nichts an diesem fall ist einfach
platz vier
sie sind sehr viel größer als das
richtig physisch bruder sich nicht
sorgen
platz drei
das ist das meinung stimmt dass amber
heard in der washington post geschrieben
hat das am 20 dezember 2018
veröffentlicht wurde nicht nicht steht
da nicht neunzehnter dezember oben auf
der seite steht da nicht neunzehnter den
sommer 2008 zehnter
platz zwei
führte
er hat eine flasche wodka gebrochen und
traf sie schnitt meinen finger ab
ditib und
die spitze meines finger ist aber ein
gutes stück
vermisse ich vermisse als
platz 10 ist etwas verrücktes sind ich
gebe einen scheiß auf verrückt das ist
verrückt du bist verrückt hast du etwas
schon diese ganze flasche gefunden
in der wir sind betrunken in dem video
richtig
das ist möglich
sie haben sich selbst ein reger glas
rotwein ein geschüttet richtig
mehr gepackt ein mega glas ja
ich habe mir ein großes glas wein ein
geschüttet ich hielt es für notwendig ob
johnny mit seiner lockeren art auch bei
der jury punkten konnte wird sich zeigen
fest steht seinen ruf marke vielleicht
verloren haben seinen humor aber noch
nicht
[Musik]
was war die frage
ok tier das man wirklich erschreckende
aber irgendwie skurrile momente wo wir
dann auch wirklich daran teilhaben
durften über mehrere tage und auch
wochen wie wird das denn für die beiden
eigentlich imagemäßig weiter gehen nach
einem urteil können die beiden überhaupt
noch fuß fassen in hollywood beide sind
ja auch schauspieler
ja also es wird für johnny depp er hat
sich damit sage ich es meinem großen
gefallen getan weil er konnte einfach an
seine charmante art zeigen und er kam
sehr gut rüber und seine fanbasis ist
dermaßen angestiegen das heißt er hat
natürlich ein busen werbezweck auch man
kann den haben wieder buchen daher
natürlich jetzt eine große unterstützung
hat die sehr stark gewachsen dass es
doch nie davor schon ein sehr
erfolgreicher beliebter schauspieler
aber durch diesen prozess ist ja richtig
weiter hoch gestiegen als es ein
wahnsinn was hier diese unterstützung
auch online und alles für amber heard
dagegen wird es wahnsinnig schwierig
weil man natürlich als hollywood
produzent mag ich kein schauspieler
besetzen der so polarisiert und man hat
die petition gesehen die aus appartement
zwei herauszuwerfen und wenn man sie
dann natürlich besetzt dann so ein berg
löschen ein feedback bekommen haben dann
lässt man natürlich davon eher die
finger man versucht keine schauspieler
zu besetzen die polarisieren und das ist
für sie ein großer nachteil ganz ein
weil sie einfach in der öffentlichen
wahrnehmung so starke so ist und man hat
auch gesagt das ist die meistgehasste
frau hollywoods momentan deswegen muss
man kann sein dass es ein paar jahren
für sie dann wieder besser wird aber sie
war davor auch schon nicht hatten sie
nicht diese riesen karriere vorzuweisen
die war so in damit deswegen kann das
wirklich sein dass es für sie jetzt
vorbei ist aber für johnny dabei wird
immer ein kino garant sein und viele
leute wollen ihn sehen jetzt noch viel
mehr als davor und da könnte man schon
sein dass dann viele hollywood
produzenten sagen wir machen jetzt
wieder einzeln mit ihm weil es
wahrscheinlich sehr viele leute dann ist
kino zieht gegen den prozess
wahrscheinlich wird dann auch sein leben
verfilmen kettenflieger für uns live vor
ort in virginia bei dem prozess johnny
depp versus amber heard der heute
wahrscheinlich zu ende geht besten dank
dir